- I got a question from Luna.
"How should I configure
permissions for my Cloud Run
Service?"
Well, Cloud Run comes
with two gatekeepers.
The first one keeps track of who
can trigger the service to run.
If I'm writing a
public web app or API,
I set this to allow
unauthenticated invocations.
For internal,
non-public services,
I set this to require
authentication.
So only accounts with a Cloud
Run invocation permission
can trigger it.
The second gatekeeper
keeps track of what
the service is allowed to do.
By default, Cloud Run uses
a service account, which
has permissions to
access databases,
file storage, et cetera.
This makes it easy
to get started.
But for a production
service, you
should create a
custom service account
that only has the minimum
permissions for the service
to do its job.
This reduces the
amount of damage
that an attack or a
stupid mistake can cause.
Happy coding.